hi hello everybody hello hello hello
hello we are back now we are coming back
up so if you can still hear me no no
we're going we're going straight we're
going on we're going long and strong if
you know what I mean ah
hmm
okay now I'm back God people do not
listen do they I frigging said that I
was going to cut the stream ah ok anyway
yeah oh if you if you want to check out
the shirts that I'm talking about I did
open a t-shirt shop click that link that
will take you to my little shop I've got
two designs up for men and women's
sweatshirts and t-shirts so thank you
everybody and we are going to get going
with the next custom story called
kidnapped by jeez 21 and Bob live is
babble it is yeah more designs will come
over time but for now this will be it
what happened to my headphones have all
answered this a few times they broke
they woke ergo I have to use these until
I can buy suitable surround sound
replacement they bloke
my new graphics card is a GTX 670 it's a
beast it is a beast it's a beast yeah my
headset was old and I didn't use it for
that I didn't use it for the microphone
anyway so I don't see the point of
getting another headset that has a
microphone I'm really just going to get
a headset that's an audiophile headset
you know really really good one anyway
we are gonna get going on kidnap so
refresh if you can't see and here we go
and here we go yes he did again 14th of
May 1843 you're matching your old start
hmm oh hello baby Justine you are
looking fine yeah yeah yeah Biblia
anyway well thank you guys thank you
guys so much one second sorry I got a
flipbook thing Wow holy hell yes thank
you guys so much for donating to me I
can't check um I think I can right miss
dolphin Nikola zulan Damon right thank
you guys so much for helping out and
donating to me if you want to help me
out personally ah oh you feel a sharp
pain is something solid hit your head
hours later you wake up in an unfamiliar
room what okey-dokey
yeah thank you guys so much for donating
there's a widget down in the description
below a chip-in widget oh I got
kidnapped oh all right then
yeah any amount helps guys I really do
appreciate it
there is a note on the desk maybe it
will tell me where I am I'm only
assuming that this guy has this accent
sandé deep ocean I need this please
thanks very much you okay there much
better
OOP so you're awake oh the second
episode you're awake
you must certainly be wondering where
you are well now let you know that you
are now a guest to my grand mansion
there is no need for you to know the
specifics of why you're here or exactly
where here is now you are presented with
two options to try to escape or remain
in this room your reasons for escape
would be logical but I will warn you now
it's not safe out there there are worse
things in being locked in this room with
no answers yeah sincerely your kidnapper
okay there you go lalalalala
okay hello guys mmm well pot of oil and
pretty much staple to the amnesia
experience starting out with in a room
and I need to escape which means they
need to find a key which means I need to
look by the painting flip no I thought
that was for sure in here no I thought
that was guaranteed behind the bed no I
thought for sure I had it then AHA found
you crowbar thank you the keys in the
fire you're a liar your pants are in the
fire cuz they are the fire whoa I know
blew your mind okay anyway
I know I know I know I'll try to hold
back on mind-blowing revelations like
that
so sorry sorry sorry ah here's my lovely
lantern seems awfully quiet maybe I
could use that crowbar but I but I just
but I use the crowbar did it break
crowbars go no wait no zone there it is
oh whoops
my bad mombi yo do the walking dead
voice but I don't have anyone to do it
with I don't have anyone to do the
walking dead void quit I can't just go
crazy and start using it on myself
Matthew some Rick masks use um you think
you'd do this all by yourself Rick you
need someone else to help you out you
think you know but you don't Shane you
think you know but you don't um
man yeah man you ask me some me ask me
something Rick Shane what do you think
you're doing with your life do you think
you're enough to get both people in oh
good okay okay I gotta whoa okay sorry
huh sorry I cannot oh sorry I cannot say
that I'm surprised most others have
tried to search for freedom as well all
they found was their own demise are you
sure you want to continue this will be
my final warning you will not survive I
will survive
because I'm a survivor yeah Wade needs
to be here otherwise it just looks like
I'm insane I'm not for it why that door
open I did mm-hmm
Wow people are still donating thank you
guys so much for helping me out that
really does help me hell I mean the new
graphics card did set me back I spent
all the money that I was gearing up to
get a new keyboard and then some on the
graphics card but it was necessary I
just I can't deal with my graphics card
dying I absolutely need a good one
so thank you guys so much man there are
a lot of the statute right yep whoop
nothing there yeah that's okay
I mean I'm doing fine oh hello Gigantor
button what did that do did that do what
did that do seriously what did that do
I'm actually confused
I pressed the button oh yeah if someone
could post my email please that would be
of help I push the button I push that
button so good I pushed it nice and firm
but jig narsing digne I like the music
it's very it actually reminds me of some
old-school horror game that I can't
quite remember right now hmm
I will push the button again every
[ __ ] with all my might I feel good I
tried the custom story is kidnapped I
boost the baton with all my might and it
did not bear it vent nah there it did
not he did not work
would it worried it uncle finds the bug
hmm another button somewhere else that
crazy talk
here we go there's something else there
might be a button somewhere else
I do not know haha
button got it ding-dong I pushed a
Bellamy [ __ ] again but I boost it is
Busia Balazs I can be SHhhh
okay so ah no well we're getting
somewhere but where we are getting I'm
not exactly sure it's awfully bright you
know it's not like pitch-black darkness
kind of an atmosphere
those are the worst kinds all right yeah
thank you guys if you want to get your
name in the raffle if you want to get
your name in the raffle for the giveaway
of a free t-shirt which is located at
the t-shirt shop you can see the designs
for yourself please share one of my
reaction compilations and then help out
and send me your name and picture take a
screenshot of it to my email ah oh yeah
mmm mmm I'm actually kind of concerned
that nothing has been happening lately
like the guy said I was gonna die so I'm
pretty sure there's something lethal
come along fairly soon yeah trogdor
actually just linked my t-shirt site if
you want to buy a t-shirt you're more
than welcome to
I'm only doing giveaways of the official
markiplier logo t-shirt so if you want
don't know what that was
ma is a letter from directly from
Stefano now I don't know his voice I
can't do his voice Martin the prison is
full
I simply cannot fit any more prisoners
into this cell tell Abraham that we will
not need any until next month what is
taking so long with those experiments
perhaps you are keeping something from
me
Stefano hmm interesting
hmm didn't find anything about here
besides another crowbar guess my other
one died Oh to do a screen shot that's
easy you have a print screen button copy
paste it copies an image on your desktop
you paste it onto like Microsoft Paint
or something and then save it I I don't
think that I'm at liberty to do the
official Stefano voice even if there was
one let's see hey you can't get outside
I mean I've said before now I'll say
this once just to say I have nothing but
respect for PewDiePie I do because he
raises a lot of money for charity and he
raises a lot of attention for smaller
indie games I have great respect for the
guy I really do know I do and I don't
like all the hate talk I don't mind
people mentioning him because he's a big
part of the community you can't get out
you can't exist in this community and
not and try to ignore him
like you just can't do it he is there
and he does good so I like that I don't
know I don't really watch PewDiePie's
videos I think he has a stuff on a voice
I'm not sure so I'm pretty sure he does
so I don't I don't want to step on
anybody's toes there yes please attach
it in an email yeah
and that's all I'll say about the
PewDiePie situation I really really do
respect the guy like seriously I do
see here and I would rather that
everyone else not worry if people
mentioned PewDiePie cuz it's not a big
deal just another another let's player
at the end of the day he's just another
guy who plays video games anyway
Stefano I cannot emphasize the
seriousness of our work at the moment
it's not your place to question my
activities so unless you want to keep
clean that strange slime out of the
cellar
I would keep quiet now I'll be going
into town for a few days to sort out our
problems with a South passage I'll be
back as soon as possible but in the
meantime Heinrich will take care of the
tests um I may do the walking dead I
mean III mean it's been staring me in
the face I kind of felt like everyone
else is doing it and you know there were
like I didn't know if I could add
anything to it but I might give it a try
aha can't hide anything from media how
do you donate well I'm glad you want to
donate just go into the description
below there's a little widget if you
press the click the chip in budget now
Adam you'll donate money straight to my
PayPal account so thank you so much I
want you to do that alright I still am
concerned that nothing has happened so
far
I mean I don't know if I mean I like it
when it kind of takes a slow pace of
things kind of builds up the tension ooh
what is that what got hell ah hello okay
I escaped that horrible prison and all
those things are after me I have to
write this little the rest is covered in
blood and is unreadable see here I've
finished with paranormal I'm done with
paranormal I think I've played it as
much as I could I got all the scares
hello okay yeah so strong oh I am the
best
yeah it's okay you don't need to send me
your youtube name that's not a big deal
I just need to know your name because I
need to be able to find you again so
that I can ship to you what huh wait a
minute he said there were others before
me in case I cannot find the exit I will
leave this key here so that anyone else
that escapes can open the door to the
wine storage where I hid a spare hammer
I also left some loved on gum in there
Dan
those creatures bite hard not sure if I
can make it mark I doubt that's me
picked up the wine storage key
right let's see here and yes for all of
you who are asking I am going to think
this oh yes thank you for sharing yeah
guys if you want to just help out other
than you know if you've already got your
name in the raffle if you want to just
help out you can always share videos
that's the biggest way that gets more
intention for my channel it really is
like there's nothing more that will help
me okay I need to get a hammer it should
be a hammer in that room okay no no no
no not that let's see here
let's see here all right nope not that
one not that one
so where is it here nope not that one
either okay there we go
I'm kind of nervous that nothing's
happening cuz I've started to go down
into the depths and it's done a good
down here
it does not look good down here
can I just say that oh no I knew it I
knew it I knew it I know something was
gonna happen
ah come on oh hey buddy hey buddy hey
buddy hey buddy how you doing how are
you doing friend did you leave good then
not me it did not move oh man oh yeah I
absolutely love my fan base seriously I
I tell I tell everybody that I have the
greatest fan in the world why are you
coming out here I have the greatest fans
at the world and I got some peril Adam
he doesn't even know I'm here what if I
was a barrel animated MMO yo alright
he's leaving he's not leaving yeah
leaving what are you doing
yeah my fans really are the best in the
world I cannot I could not ask for
better fans will he do was he doing he's
coming back yep you see me now
I got a barrel right here yep this is
totally working dude good burger I gotta
put it again I got a hammer why I get
amber getting here thing Dolman hammer
yeah
Rowe Qingming fall rib adjudant twister
di I remember that name twister D you
had to get out of that place as soon as
possible
I haven't seen you twister D in a long
time unless you've been here and you've
been buried by the comments was it
perfectly understandable all right so
the monsters have finally been unleashed
anything of value ah nothing anything of
value I don't think I was supposed to be
able to come back here nope okay look no
no no oh no oh no Ariel hey Lizzie sacks
it sounds familiar
man it's hard to remember I mean back in
the day I used to have like maximum of
50 viewers so it's real
okay that's weird
I think I'm just kidding over okay there
are very few who oh this is oh there's a
kidnapper there are very few who'll
understand why I did what I did I think
it's safe to say there's no going back
in these few notes I would try to
explain the reasons for my actions
in simple terms we capture torture and
eventually kill people
the reason Harbor is much more
complicated those we choose to apply
abduct are not allowed to live we judge
them based on their lifestyle based on
the clothes they wear and the people
they mock I provide a service for
humanity and act as the almighty God's
servant in order to appreciate life and
those around you we must set an example
and rid the world of those who take it
for granted the rich and spice to
nothing but a burden to society the rest
of their note is torn off maybe I can
find the missing pieces elsewhere and
see here
mmm no finally we have returned I don't
know what exactly what I'm looking for
down here it's just kind of a big empty
area not that that is in my favorite
type of area but no Gupta in there oh oh
it's not good good not good not good at
all not good there yells in here
no okay it's all sorted when a good
friend of mine mr. Silver's began
abducting middle-class families from the
north Glenn he confessed his crime to me
one night so I told him he would go to
hell for his actions if he does not
repent he spiraled he smiled at me and
said it was God's will that they die
you've said it was the right thing to do
okay I don't know why these mechanical
mannequins are being assembled there I
don't like it though I don't like it
there's no no in no good there's no good
hey look it's some whiskey I have no
idea
oh no I'm not gonna talk I'm not gonna
try slender prison again sorry folks
it's not gonna happen cuz at this point
I wouldn't even be scared with it I
would not and that's just not fun and
I'll just be bashing my head against the
wall trying to beat the clock reminds me
of my old Raving days when I used to
play World of Warcraft
even if I got eight pages I doubt that I
would ever give to the exit so sorry
folks
slender prison is shelved for life good
boy
mm-hmm where am I I'm goin on here I
just went in a big circle there's slime
blocking the way wait oh yeah I have a
frickin crowbar I'm an idiot I'm an
idiot I'm an idiot okay I'm an idiot I
forgot that I had that nope not that one
I'm gonna run out of oil good dark good
dark there we go looks like a crowbar
bit the best bit the dust
what have we done we've been killing
people for the heat for three years now
the bodies have piled up and the
creatures are out of control there is no
good deed in what we are doing God will
not protect us nor will he acknowledge
our actions as a sign of our devotion we
have been cursed Stephano ran into the
cellar with his prison key there's no
way I can give there before the
creatures I'm going to kill at least one
of them before I meet my end forgive me
Lord
interesting key get out of here fast
I agree I agree right who wears it Rizzy
Wow look here I use this enemas way
it's a prison key okay whatever okay Oh
gonna go okay I'm fine I'm fine fine
fine I'm fine and all this is all wrong
oh this Royce you rate while I read this
note hmm the day after day I wash as
thousands are left to suffer from the
plague and thousands more are forced to
live amongst I know it is buying time
compassion is nowhere to be seen wealth
and upper-class turn the other way and I
am the only person left who can make
difference I will make them see the evil
of their ways I will make them
experience what they have forsaken okay
okay okay okay
Oh
Oh remember remember where am i where am
i going to be a go well leggo my eggo
okay I guess I just did just run
straight out and not go anywhere yeah I
must burn I'm going to run I'm running
I'm running
I must tread softly and easy pray if I'm
not careful oh man oh man oh okay all
right now oh so what did I get I get the
prison key oh you had to get out of that
place as soon as possible
let's just get kidnapped again did I I
just got kidnapped again didn't I
I just got kidnapped again doctor just a
mother oh god another Justine music
why did they leave me in here with a
drill and a pot of acid
well I hate that music that music is
like the worst I mean it's great but
it's so hmm it's just so good
so have it
oh god seriously
my lantern broke maybe I could take that
torch with me maybe you could stop
thinking so insanely well I guess I can
Oh what do you know I can do that that's
weird hmm oh yeah that's happened before
I've had that I've had that before okay
man that would be an annoying mechanic
but it would kind of make it a bit more
atmospheric to just have to carry around
a torch all the time
you're dead stop moaning about it today
I woke up in a cell the smell smelled
awful in my head was dazed with pain
someone shouted is someone there it was
another prisoner we had a long
conversation mostly about the outside
world he asked me so many questions you
could tell that he had been there for a
long time
why are what he's keeping him there why
are these men keeping us here what have
we done day 2 today I asked the old
person why we were kept here
he said they kept us here because we
have turned our backs on society because
we have fueled our selfish desires with
money they torture us because we have
been negligent towards others and must
suffer for it I have never seen sight
he's under bail and could they be
referring to that day 10 so hungry so
thirsty they gave us a bb's of the bread
per week it seems and just a few drops
of water day 30 they have tortured me
for weeks the pain is unbearable
the prisoner was killed sometime this
morning it's green continued through the
night
how what did they do to him to make him
suffer for so long day 400 I can't I
believe I'm still breathing days come
and go loser is coming go why they give
me a lie for so long I don't even
remember what my children look like
I hope they will come for me soon and
then my suffering hey I have a knack for
reading I'm good at reading I'm good at
speaking it's some of my favorite things
to do kind of convenient being that I am
I do let's place it'd be bad if I was
bad at talking then again there are a
lot of lets players that are bad at
talking
ah all right so I gotta get up there I
suppose
was it keep rolling stop rolling all
right here we go
OOP OOP huh yep come on
yeah move this out of the way thank you
Fang cube and here we go
come on come on get in there get in
there get oh you shut up oh you son of a
[ __ ]
you're sort of up I swear I will Jack
slap you so hard
sit down there on my hot little hole ah
hold on to the bed
what are you gotta be kidding me it
rolled under the bed are you faring you
gotta be you gotta recover
stop moving
okay I want to get three there now thank
you
can I not do that okay never mind I
guess I can't
hey come on come on come on I'm fine I
guess you can't I guess you can't get
out of there I guess you can't go that
way that was it's a big lie ah if you're
doing it let's play
you either have one or two styles you
have the style where you are promoting
the game you're playing or you're
promoting you as an entertainer and if
you're an entertainer you got to keep up
with the entertainment meaning there are
times when you can focus really hard but
most of the time you got to keep going
that fool Martin he's ran off thinking
that God is cursed us that these
creatures are its creation our Lord has
granted me the ability to create these
creatures I have found a lasting
redemption for these sinners I have
saved them from what they used to be
without mom though a work cannot
continue and I'm afraid that my creation
will soon be too numerous for me to
handle I'm getting out of here tonight
and I will be leaving behind this key to
anyone who happens to need it I will
continue my work and any who wish to
follow me may do so let's see okay
bye-bye see and there's a chest here
open up please Wow ain't nothing in
there
fantastic all right
here we are moving forward again Oh
sassafras sassafras oh I get it I don't
need to climb up I need to climb down oh
I need to get this out of the way stop
rolling you torch you torch bastard why
do you do this into me get off there
come on come on oh come on please
please get okay Oh No yeah thank you
oh man what a pain in the balls nope
uh-huh can't get through there oh oh
that's fine
oh that's fine that's fine learn why is
it in slo-mo because there are 707
people in the chat and if it was not
then it would be out of control actually
you know what hmm why is it in slo-mo
I'm curious I didn't I didn't authorize
I didn't tell people to do slo-mo I'm
curious what is it who put it in slo-mo
who put it in slo-mo
come on Monica peir Emily wanted it in
slow-mo curious why it's not that it was
that out of control I mean people even
if it's in slow-mo the only reason that
it would be spamming is if is if someone
the same person said something over and
over again and moobot would take care of
that anyway I mean everyone if everyone
said one thing at once it would still
look like spam just because there's so
many things God dang it
I can't huh I'm confused as to what I'm
supposed to do I think I'm supposed to
be able to get through here that's what
it's for and that's why I can move it I
just can't seem to jump through her yeah
I just I just can't seem to get through
here hmm
like am I am I going am I going in the
correct way am i doing it the correct
way am I supposed to go through here
just out of curiosity Oh Crouch Oh am I
supposed to crouch is that what I'm
supposed to do oh no tell me more about
what I'm told to do that what a grouch
yeah yeah this one was an eight point
seven or something I think
let's see key oh I have a key what did I
get a key when did I get a key okay not
that one obviously when did I win did I
get a key
I lost my torch but I don't care it's
annoying no not there
no it's here nope not dear
there no durian here but there is a hole
in the wall yes alright I'll go get the
torch gap yes yes come on come on here
we go yep yep okay here we go
whoop who do I should have noticed this
hole in the wall a long time ago hole in
the wall
excuse me I need more hole in that wall
hip hip hip hip hip
come on aw come on come on oh wait no
that's what I'm fine I'm gonna do it I'm
an idiot
there we go I got it now he I have it
now I have it now
Oh
oh boy oh boy a news gonna happen god
this song I knew yeah
picked up a key
I wouldn't have needed that key if I
never went in that room okay
all right David ah I see you hollow
needle fiercely mannequins are just a
special breed of Horror special breed of
[ __ ]
oh you have got to okay there we go oh
this is annoying as balls this over I
know I am hockey to freedom hollow pic
to freedom
no no drill to freedom
no it's running it's rolling away isn't
it yeah it is it's rolling away
no strange that's where I came from
no it's not oh no it's not old Shawn
rolling I hate that ding Joe much hammer
give me that oh come on I want the
hammer well what's the point of this
then hmm
I got everything I tried it all on that
shut up guy oh wait no duh this this
place there we go
I'm an idiot oh really wait I want you
to all see this what
what are you spin me right round baby
right round perpetual spinning physics
perfectly logical perfectly logical give
me thank you thank you no aha
chemistry pout no finally we have
returned
they'll hear besides the dead pig right
there we go I have a chemistry pot but I
don't know what to do with it I don't
own oh yes I do I do i do there was a
there was a pot of acid right back in
the beginning in my cell I'm so smart
I'm doing work
Thank You Mart oh look how smart I am
yeah I'm the Marty it yeah hums Oh Mart
yep yep yep yep yep
what hey don't go back here you can't
run away from me
Torche yes
and then sploosh and then I follow oh I
never felt but better as I breezed in
the fresh air I finally found the exit I
was finally free oh this does not look
free this doesn't look very free man
okay's free oh oh boo yeah that was
another good one that was another good I
like that I like that a lot
I mean some of the things were kind of
wonky but you know it was good and I did
it yeah oh I'm so smart I'm just the
best that there ever ever ever ever ever
works oh how do you enter the raffle
it's it's incredibly simple all you need
to do is share one of my reaction
compilations doesn't matter which and
take a screenshot of you posting it to
whatever Twitter or Facebook whatever
doesn't matter and then all you need to
do is send it to me at this email
address
one second I got to get out of it I
can't quite
out yet a dududududududu goat oh yes one
more we're gonna do one more tonight
we're gonna do one more we are gonna do
one more you screenshot very easily by
hitting the Print Screen button okay
anyway can I get out of there thank you
let's see yeah let's see yeah no just
one more just one more for tonight but
I'm gonna make it a good one a more
highly rated one than the ones I have
been playing this next one will be
phenomenal mmm
and if you once you share send it to
this email address caps and all actually
kept still matter and also I guess I'll
take another moment to thank you guys so
much for joining me here my name is
markiplier case you didn't know thank
you super atomic for coming to this live
stream there's still more content
available I just told everyone how to
give you the raffle for the shirts on
click on the link that people have been
posting for the Spreadshirt site that
links directly to my new t-shirt store
where you can you can find t-shirts of
mine that if you want to buy I tried to
get the price down on these so it's not
exorbitant than anything like that so
anyway we're not done yet we're not done
yet we're not done yet we are not done
yet so hold on hold on to your horses
also I want to I want to make sure that
I give um these people that do Tracy
summer donated $30 thank you so much
Tracy I really do appreciate it $5.00
from Nicola Gibson thank you thank you
for helping me out
$20 from Daymond right you are the best
you all are the best thank you again $20
from Ashley mcdougal thank you guys you
guys literally I say that I have the
best fans of the world and you guys are
willing to help me out like this I mean
hopefully someday soon I won't need to
take donations anymore I just won't do
it anymore so thank you guys so much
another $20 from Noah trucks thank you
thank you thank you thank you $20 from
Jennifer dissy de Cicco de Cicco I think
that's anyway thank you again for
helping me out you you don't know how
much helps
and holy crap $50 from amv Davis
Wow Thank You Amanda Davis that's who it
is thank you thank you so much what is
the most and I'm not gonna throw that
around I think the most was like 200 but
it's it's pretty it's just pretty
incredible what people have done for me
9:35 from Wayne yang thank you again
everybody thank you so much see ten
dollars from Ana gold steals thank you
Thank You Ana thank you so much and 15
dollars from Stephen Swick thank you
Thank You Steven I just I keep saying
thank you and God man I'm just so happy
that you guys are willing to help me out
like this and five dollars from till
Steinmetz and one Wharf two dollars from
Elise graves thank you so much any
amount helps oh thank you guys anyway so
I'm going to cut the stream real quick I
will be back in just a second the
screams gonna go out for a few seconds
refresh until it comes back I'm still
here we're gonna do one more custom
story for you guys so I will be right
back